we've got a big bathroom debate to talk
about
okay first let me tell you
this all started on chelsea handler's
instagram because she posted a pic it
was so fun everybody chimed in and it
posed a very simple question do you like
your toilet paper over or under
well i proudly planted my flag for under
on social media and ross i got clobbered
see even you guys are moaning what am i
missing everybody ripped into me
everyone was like oh my god it's only
one way
drew i thought i knew you but i don't
know you
under are you out of your mind
i don't get it what's wrong with that
it's just
wrong is what's wrong with it
we just happen to have these fantastic
things right here
because the titans of tp at continental
took notice and they reached out to us
and today we're teaming up with
continental to settle this debate once
and for all so hands raised if you are
an over
yeah
thank you
wait you didn't raise your hand
you're in the back
are you and ender
my husband and i argue about this all
the time all the time and i'm like it
just it's uncomfortable under is better
it feels easier
well sandra apparently we're animals
no we're ross why well okay look at we
have we have our exhibit exhibit a and
exhibit b here drew is in under and look
how far you have to reach to get it and
i i can't even read it because it's
right there let me allow me to put it
right here and you won't have that look
how easy mine's like welcoming it's like
hi ross i'm right here and i just say
thank you so much because
thank you and now done yours is like
oh it's so hot
forget it
here is why i love an under can i just
i'll i'll fight for sandra and i okay
see when i go under you know a lot of
the times there's a thing you just rip
it off and you rip it towards you but
when i go over this happens
and i waste all this toilet paper
i mean it's a fair point but you're
still wrong well no matter which way
your toilet paper rolls and i think we
can all agree there's no wrong way to
roll as long as you down there care
i think that there is no right or wrong
it's all personal preference okay well
okay we'll agree to disagree on this one
drew thank you cotton now
[Music]